just like old times American troops in
Subic Bay showcasing their hardware and
capabilities as part of the largest ever
joint drills between the Philippines and
the United States
for nearly 100 years this was a U.S
naval base until 1991 when the
Philippine Senate voted to shut it down
local officials say they welcome U.S
soldiers with open arms
it benefits us it benefits the local
community in terms of Commerce and
employment whenever these foreign
military vessels call Port here in Subic
Subic isn't one of the four new sites
the Philippine government under
President Ferdinand Marcos Jr has
granted the U.S military access to
but it is a case study for areas that
were chosen
U.S vessels like the one behind me are a
constant presence here in Subic as many
as 100 of them dock every year for a
number of reasons including to refuel
and get repairs done in fact it was
during one of those routine visits in
2014 when Jennifer laude a Filipino
transgender woman was murdered by an
American serviceman
Joseph Scott Pemberton a U.S marine was
convicted of killing laude but was
pardoned by former president Rodrigo
duterte in 2020 and set back to the U.S
the murder of Jennifer laude is not an
isolated case the 16
000 cases of prostitution that arose in
Olongapo alone
and the 8600 children ameritian children
that were left behind
and like Subic Bay Cagayan which will
host U.S forces in two of its bases it's
close to Taiwan the focal point of much
of the antagonism between the U.S and
China cagayan's Governor Manuel Mamba
opposes the plan we know Taiwan is a
power okay
no it has always been that way
and we know that uh
America would always try to
boldly its way again here
the national government insists the deal
only aims to shore up the country's
defenses the Philippines Foreign Affairs
secretary Enrique Manalo categorically
stating the U.S won't be allowed to
stockpile weapons for a conflict over
Taiwan
partner below Al Jazeera Subic Bay the
Philippines